i love doing the podcast i feel like
it's like you know when you were coming
up in comedy there's different mediums i
feel like podcast is the medium now for
somebody like me to get my
you know that's how i'm selling tickets
now through that it's not for me it's
not really about television it's i would
like to do it but it's really like the
podcast podcast podcast that's that's
how the people are but podcast is like
television you can watch it on youtube
people can watch it you can listen to it
you're not working for the man you know
you're not on television i do television
too but and this is my
you know respite but you're but you're
in a different thing because you know
you're you've been doing television you
did television when it mattered and
that's how we all heard when it was
invented when it was invented and so my
for me now it's like uh it's this weird
thing we're at in entertainment where
it's like the some of the tv execs don't
understand that their medium isn't as
important where i could just put not
that it's not important but
i can just put my microphones up and
hire my guy who i work with shout out to
homeless pimp to just come over to my
house and set up that's my producer's
name it's just uh
homeless pimp doesn't nobody change his
name from to mike levin for show
business mike well it's actually no very
very careful mike lavin he's wants to
let you know he's not but he's not you
or she no no no no no no no very
important very important yeah
he got very upset when i said oh that's
why he went with homeless pimp because
homeless pimp is definitely not jewish
not jewish yes and um not to be confused
with homeland homeless pimpsky homeless
pimsky or homeless pimple is another guy
out there um and uh yeah so that's what
um
i had a cbs sitcom pilot in 2016 i
thought it was going to be my big break
and then it didn't go filmed it didn't
go and then i was like oh i got a little
girl you know what's weird that people
like you young people who who just come
into this business you aspire to do
television yes i don't get that at all
because the number i'm on the like the
number one television show on nbc it is
a smash on any given day if
if eight or nine million people
tune in for that one day right and then
it's gone right any post you put up on
any platform or your podcast i would
imagine that's a fraction
of how how many people listen a month to
your podcast oh the month yeah the month
is would be more than okay not in one
day no i know but it's but that's why it
lives right well you know that even with
agt when they post online aren't they
getting way more views online they're
more excited about that we get a billion
views i believe it i i i think that um
you know there's a place for it but i
think like i had to make the decision
because you're right we there we was
this thing in 2016 i was like
and some of my peers still think you tv
and movies and all that's the way but in
2016 i was like i got a little girl like
this pilot didn't go i just gave a year
of it to my a year of my life to it i
thought les moonves told me i was going
to be the next ray romano and then it's
gone and i'm like i can't live like this
i can't put my career in the hands of
some corporation so i was like i'm going
online i'm doing the podcast and then
now it's all changed and now it's at a
weird place where it's like
it's almost like reverse where it's like
i don't have you have to convince me to
do your show i don't have to convince
you i don't want to audition for your
show you have to tell me why you want me
to do that because i literally make the
living that i've always dreamed of from
my house with my family i get to pick my
kids up from school i'm like then i go
on the road i sell the tickets i sell
the theaters i'm like what why then you
want me to go what go to la for three
months and go on an nbc show that you
said no nobody's going to see more
people see my podcast and they and some
of these and you don't understand and
you can't do what you do you can't no
you can't do what you're known for you
can't do what your audience wants to
hear no you can't
no so you're just that's legitimately
selling out which i do all the time i'm
a proponent of selling out i am sold out
i'm the most sold out person you will
meet in the next two weeks but literally
you're the best at it i am
you could buy me you couldn't i
really yes but you but you when selling
out like you was was the way to do it
right it's just not anymore you know i'm
like an old aged wine i'm you look you
don't drink it you don't use it you just
but i'm a collectible
you're a collectible i am a colleague i
am
[Music]
you